the guns finally turn on burning sort of
Michael Bloomberg keeps getting clocked
and Joe Biden wants you to know that
he's going to say some words dagnabbit
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
my savvy fans secure their internet join
them expressvpn calm / man so have you
been noticing as the stock market has
been plummeting over the last couple of
days mean down like almost a 2,000
points over the last couple of days the
single largest stock market drop over
two days since 2008 it's been pretty
brutal and that's been largely due to
coronavirus and the disruption of global
supply chains you know what's one thing
that has actually gone up is gold gold
continues to go up as people look for a
safe haven maybe now would be a good
time for you to diversify at least a
little bit into precious metals and
people I trust to do that you know them
Birch gold what is your plan to
safeguard your savings considering we
really are living in a pretty
unpredictable and unstable time if you
haven't yet taken the first step of
requesting a free information kit on
gold go ahead and do it if you haven't
converted a portion of your eligible IRA
or 401k to an IRA and precious metals
have that conversation Birch gold will
go to work and make things super simple
for you there's no obligation so you
have nothing to lose to take that first
step
Birch gold group has thousands of
satisfied customers countless five-star
reviews and a plus rating with the
Better Business Bureau Tech's been - 47
47 47 during the month of February when
you open an IRA in precious metals you
will get a signed copy of my book the
right side of history for free it is the
end of February so this would be it
again you have to text my name Ben - 47
47 47 this month it is almost over open
an IRA and precious metals get a signed
copy of my book the right side of
history again just as a responsible
person you should be at least a little
bit diversified into precious metals the
folks at Birch gold can help you text my
name Ben - 47 47 47 - get started right
now okay so last night was the final
democratic debate the matter because
once we hit South Carolina the suckers
over here's the bottom line if Joe Biden
does not win South Carolina walking away
it can't be a close victory he has to
win by probably double digits unless Joe
Biden has a massive victory in South
Carolina this sucker is over Bernie
Sanders as your nominee Michael
Bloomberg has been sinking and a lot of
the state and national polling Nate
Silver points out the Michael Bloomberg
is now receding back toward the fields
he'd gotten up to close to 20 percent
now he is receding back down toward 11
percent in a lot of the national poll
and you're seeing the same thing
happening in a lot of the state polling
so he's just clogging up that moderate
Lane right instead of him actually
clearing the moderate lane instead of
Biden clearing the moderate Lane he just
becomes another one of these also-rans
Krabbe bucket where every crab is
dragging on all the other crabs Budaj
edge and Klobuchar and Biden and
Bloomberg and they're all tearing each
other down the newest economist YouGov
poll has Bernie up at 30 percent Biden
at 20 Bloomberg at 11 and Warren at 16
and boo to judge at 9 so Bloomberg is
not rising up from the field in any of
the national polling you're seeing the
same thing happened in the Emerson poll
that has Bloomberg all the way down at
14 ABC news/washington post poll has him
down at 14 NBC news/wall Street Journal
poll has Bloomberg down at 14 and yet
bizarrely last night it was Michael
Bloomberg who's at the tip of
everybody's tongue in a lot of the
debate last night which makes no sense
because as we all know Bernie Sanders is
your national frontrunner right now now
the polls in South Carolina show that
Biden does continue to have a lead but
how big that lead is I mean it could be
anybody's guess if there are two polls
in the last 30 in the last 48 hours well
three polls in the last 48 hours
if one from CBS News you gov and it
shows Biden up 28:23 on Sanders so a
fairly narrow lead and then you have one
from NBC News Maris that has Biden up
just four points on Sanders and within
margin of error at 27 to 23 and then
there's a Public Policy Polling poll
which is a democratic firm and that
shows Biden all the way up to 36 percent
with Sanders all the way down at 21% so
if Biden were to blow out Bernie in
South Carolina then what you could see
on Super Tuesday is the two of them
really start to split votes in a serious
way you could see Biden run the table in
the south and you could see Bernie pick
up votes in places like California and
Bloomberg at that point would be the
complicating factor not Biden now the
logic so far has been that if Biden
doesn't win South Carolina he needs to
drop out so that somebody else has a
shot at that moderate lane but if Biden
wins South Carolina really would behoove
Bloomberg to drop out and toss his money
behind Biden if he doesn't want to see
an open socialist as the nominee the
bottom line here though is that Bernie
does have the clearest path to the
nomination at this point 538 continues
to put his odds of taking the nomination
as the highest odds about two and five
they say that no majority is still at 2
& 5 they've got Biden at 1 and 9 and
Bloomberg is down in town at 1 in 50 so
Sanders was the was the front-runner
last night and with Sanders attacked
like the front-runner
the answer of course is no he was not
and the very beginning of the debate for
the first they had a big debate in South
Carolina then the first I don't know 10
minutes of the debate people started
trying to launch attacks on Bernie now
the biggest problem with launching
I'm Bernie if you are democrat is the
problem that a lot of Republicans had
launching attacks on Trump what's the
angle exactly what's the angle now
with Trump you could try and attack him
from the right you could say that he
wasn't he wasn't right-wing enough he
wasn't he wasn't sort of cueing the line
enough on various conservative issues
that he was a newcomer on the abortion
issue that he was a newcomer on the
immigration issue but Trump was willing
to say whatever extreme thing he had to
say in order to shore up the base and
Bernie it's sort of the same thing the
attacks on Bernie that are going to
damage him in a general election come
from his right but the base is not
significantly to Bernie Sanders is right
or at least they appear not to be they
appear to be willing to fall for his lie
that Medicare for all means that you get
to keep your doctor they appear to be
willing to fall for his lies that he's
gonna come up with 60 trillion dollars
to pay for all of this stuff they appear
to be willing to go along with his
ridiculous heresy so that means that
most of the attacks on Bernie last night
sort of fell flat because Bernie and his
perspective are indeed fairly popular
inside the Democratic Party and as
Bernie gains credence as a national
presidential candidate people are
willing to shunt aside their fears and
simply jump on board the bandwagon
the only person last night there they're
only two people last night who really
tried to take it to Bernie in any
serious way it really was Bloomberg and
who to judge Biden really didn't try to
take it to Sanders in any serious way
Warren I mean honestly I'm shocked at
how bad these folks are debate I am
shocked at it Elizabeth Warren last
night was going out of her way to attack
Bloomberg while leaving Bernie alone
because she clearly wants the VP slot
from Bernie and I'm just shocked at
Bloomberg didn't say that straight out
really I'm surprised by that I'm
surprised that when Warren was attacking
Bloomberg Bloomberg didn't say listen
Elizabeth I know that you are the
front-runner in this race for a short
period of time and then Bernie ate your
lunch I know you're desperately hoping
to be Bernie's vice president I get all
of that but I don't understand why
you're attacking me that's not gonna
make you Bernie's vice president it
would've been devastating for her but
Bloomberg nobody's willing to call
anybody out except for Bloomberg because
Bloomberg is the safe territory he's a
billionaire he used to be a Republican
and so it's easy to attack Bloomberg
because you know that your base is
behind you on most of those attacks it's
harder to attack burning as we will see
Bernie actually had a pretty bad debate
last night Bernie was ranting and raving
like the old communist lunatic that he
is but none of that matters cuz
everybody knows that he's an old
communist lunatic meanwhile if you had
to grade the candidates last night
here is your here's your preliminary
grade so you give Bernie basically a D
but it doesn't matter maybe n a is
probably the better grade not applicable
because it really doesn't matter all he
had to do his escape getting destroyed
last night and he basically did Joe
Biden had probably his best debate his
debate basically consisted of him
standing there and shouting that he
wanted more time to talk into the
microphone and then not actually knowing
what to say into the microphone as we
will see it was kind of amusing he kept
doing it over and over and over but it
was Joe Biden trying to demonstrate that
he is actually a living functional human
being with a brain that still has
occasional flickers of light in it and
then you had Peabody Judge who again
turn in a very smooth debate and the
problem for people who to judge is that
the smoothness of his debating skills is
not gonna make up for the fact that
Buddha judge has no national appeal and
can't even win his home state of Indiana
yet Amy Klobuchar who is an also-ran
she had a fine debate but Amy Klobuchar
has never been able to generate any
electricity on this stage yet Tom Steyer
now it was funny people last night were
tweeting why is why are people attacking
Tom sir the reason people are attacking
Tom Steyer has become is because Tom
Steyer actually has a fairly significant
share percentage in South Carolina like
stires the is there are only three
people running in double digits in the
RealClearPolitics polling average in
South Carolina Biden Sanders in steyr
conspire has dumped millions upon
millions of dollars into South Carolina
that's the reason that Biden was going
after steyr trying to take away support
from Steyr steyr had what for him was a
fine debate but obviously he's going
nowhere and and nowhere fast
so it was a pretty lackluster debate the
moderation has come under a lot of
scrutiny because the moderators really
did not take control of the debate as
you will see was incredibly messy people
could not get a word in edgewise
everybody was so desperate to talk that
you couldn't even get a clean hit in on
anyone if the debate last week was
notable because everybody was just sort
of spraying each other with bullets last
night was a clown car remember who's
sort of balking each other with plastic
hammers I was making the pretty sound
now that really was the the sound on the
sound last week was the sound of
gunshots the shut the sound last night
was written as people each other with
the little plastic hammers that you get
from the arcade okay so here's how it
began it began with with various other
candidates attacking Bernie Sanders and
doing so in fairly weak terms we'll get
to that in just one second first let us
talk about the necessity to lock
at night you've locked your doors at
night right I mean why would you leave
in front door open chances are nobody's
gonna walk in but you'd be a fool to
leave your front door open you wouldn't
leave your car unlocked on the street
chances are you're Carl be fine but it
would be stupid I mean with a quick
flick of a wrist you can make sure that
your entire car is protected why
wouldn't you do that with your internet
activity
they're just hackers out there they are
waiting to get ahold of your credit card
number there are big ISPs who are
waiting to get a hold of all of your
data so they can monetize your data well
your data is your data what you do
online is your business and this is why
you should have a VPN and the VPN that I
use is expressvpn expressvpn puts a stop
to all of this it creates a secure
encrypted tunnel between your device and
the internet so your online activity
cannot be seen by anyone expressvpn it
works on all your devices phones laptops
even routers so everyone who shares your
Wi-Fi can still be protected even if
they don't have expressvpn the best part
is using Express VPN is really really
easy right you install it on your
computer it runs in the background you
hit one button you're now protected it
doesn't slow down your computer and the
way a lot of other VPNs do and it's not
gonna cost you a fortune so if you're
like me and you believe your online
activity is your business secure your
online activity today visit expressvpn
comm slash pen today use my exclusive
link expr ESS VPN comm slash Ben and get
an extra three months for free
that's expressive VPN calm slash Ben
again expressvpn calm slash man ok so
the debate began with a few different
attacks on Bernie Sanders and it was
everybody trying to kind of try their
line the biggest line that everybody was
trying is that bernie is unelectable now
the problem with this is that if you
want to make the case that bernie is
unelectable this is the case that biden
has been making all along and it's true
bernie has serious flexibility issues
and there's an analysis from Vox
yesterday that specifically talked about
the fact that Bernie would have to get
like 55 percent youth turnout which is
not a thing that's going to happen if he
hopes to make up for all the different
for all of the sort of deficiencies he
has with suburban women and with
moderates and with independents and that
is not going to happen all right so the
fact that bernie is the least electable
of these Democratic candidates and that
the National polling right now does not
reflect any any of the damaging material
that will go out against Bernie I mean
if you think that all the Oppo research
material that I've been talking about on
the show for years and all the stuff
that I've talked about for years ranging
from Bernie's supremely creepy pieces
back in the 1970s in which he actively
talks about why young children should
run around naked and touch each other's
genitals to
prevent the pornography industry from
making money he actually wrote that yeah
I didn't write that he wrote that he
wrote it when he was 30 years old he was
not a child and do you think that's not
gonna come up you're wrong if you think
that Bernie's life as a derelict loser
until he was 39 years old and who's
elected mayor of Burlington is not gonna
come up
you are wrong if you think that Bernie's
positions back in the 1970s in which he
embraced every authoritarianism he could
find that those are not going to come up
you are wrong
right they will come up and he will not
get the soft-pedal treatment that he's
been getting from the media he will not
get the soft-pedal treatment got last
night from the Democrats he will get the
full Trump and Trump is a weapon right
Trump in 2016 I made this point a
thousand times Trump is a hammer
sometimes he gets a nail and it's
delicious and sometimes he it's a baby
and it is less so hitting Bernie Sanders
will be hitting a nail and will be
hitting a nail repeatedly until the
until the nail splinters because the
fact is that Bernie Sanders is right for
Apple material Donald Trump isn't going
to figuratively hit Bernie Sanders with
a kitchen sink Donald Trump may in fact
go down to the kitchen of the hotel
where they are holding the debate pry a
sink off the wall bring it up into the
debate hall and hit Bernie Sanders
physically with a sink okay be the best
food rattled Trump is the man has no
limits like none and so for Bernie
that's really bad because bernie is
still flying high on this I have a great
solution for the future sure it's the
same vision as Karl Marx but it's a
great vision why couldn't we not do this
okay
Trump is gonna have none of that as we
will see even the Democrat attacks on
Bernie's Marxism last night fell flat
mainly because a lot of the Democrats
have sort of the same central premises
as Bernie they just don't like how
bernie is going about reaching his
proposed conclusions okay so here's how
the attacks start so Michael Bloomberg
opens this thing up and he says okay
Vladimir Putin would like for would like
for Bernie Sanders to get the nomination
because they want to see Trump elected
now this is really kind of ridiculous
what Bloomberg is saying because the
truth is that basic latest Intel
suggests the opposite the latest Intel
suggests that the Russians don't just
want Bernie nominated they want Bernie
to win and the Washington Post reported
that why wouldn't they want him to win
he's a fellow traveler I mean the guys
the guys Wallace the guy is the the
reporter from the New York Times circa
1932 going around Ukraine talking about
how they've solved all problems of
feeding the public in Bernie is a
lifelong communist fellow-traveller of
course Vladimir Putin wants me
president is there it could a rational
person think otherwise who do you think
Putin loans do you think he wants the
guy who yes he believes he's been able
to play Trump there's no question Putin
thinks he's been able to play Trump but
do you think that Putin wants the guy
who is strengthen the United States
military and Hanan deadly aid to Ukraine
or do you think he wants the guy who
speaks fondly of Vladimir Lenin I am not
kidding Bernie Sanders speaks fondly in
1988 he came back from the Soviet Union
and talked about how the Soviet Union
was finally achieving the visions of
1917 which is Leninism okay so here's
Michael Bloomberg getting he can't even
get this hit right right none of the
hits on Sanders stuck because they're
all done badly and because they're not
true at least in half so here is
Bloomberg even while hitting Bernie
pulling his punches on Vladimir Putin I
think that Donald Trump thinks that
would be better if he's president I do
not think so Vladimir Putin thinks that
Donald Trump is should be present United
States and that's why Russia is helping
you get all the you lose him let me tell
this to Putin okay I'm not a good friend
the President Xi of China I think
President Xi is an authoritarian leader
and let me tell mr. Putin who interfered
in the 2016 election try to bring
Americans against Americans a mr. Putin
if I'm president the United States trust
me you're not gonna interfere in any
more American elections you won't have
to because this is no way out and I'm
Kevin Costner why would you interfere in
the American elections because the
threat is coming from inside the house
I'm sure if Aladdin or put his quickie
in his boots it being at the geriatric
communist I'm sure he's just Vladimir
Putin's like oh no I mean if Bernie
becomes president well then I won't have
to do anything that's come on come on
okay but he is right that that as we
will see Bloomberg is very warmt orgies
and paying above China and that is a
flaw for for Michael Bloomberg right
there's one of the problems for Michael
Bloomberg also it is worth noting that
Bernie has talked about the wonders of
China before as well so again there's
there's no authoritarian leader who's a
communist on planet Earth where Bernie
hasn't paid lip service to I don't click
to a floor turn ISM but I'd sure like
their literacy programs and their bread
lines go to more of the failed attacks
on Bernie Sanders last night in just one
second first let's talk about
great meaningful gift so over the mantle
in my house
I have a painted portrait of my family
and it's just beautiful and didn't cost
me a fortune because I went to paint
your life calm it is fantastic so what
do they do over a painter life calm
here's what happens you can send them a
picture and then you can pick an artist
and the artist will turn your picture
into a painted portrait and you can work
with the artist to get it exactly right
so you can have an original painting of
yourself your kids family a special
place a cherished pet at a price you can
afford from paint your life calm it's a
true painting done by hand by a
world-class artist created from your
favorite photo there's no risk if you
don't love the final painting your money
is promptly refunded with paint your
life you get your favorite moments
transformed into a work of art that will
be seen every day and cherished forever
it really makes our house that much
nicer it's wonderful for me to walk in
and see pictures of my kids I just love
it it's one of my favorite things in my
house and you right now can do this
it doesn't cost you a fortune again all
you have to do is get a limited there's
a limited time offer right now you get
30% off your painting that is correct
off and free shipping to get that
special offer text the word been to
64,000 that is my name been to 64,000
texts Ben ven to 64,000 go check it out
right now it's pretty fantastic paint
your life calm text Ben 264 thousand for
the special deal 30% off your painting
in free shipping okay so Bloomberg
launches the initial attack that's a
failure then there's Elizabeth Warren
who is desperately trying to cling to
the notion that she is going to be
Bernie's VP so she sort of hits him and
she sort of dozens her hit is I love
everything that Bernie is saying Bernie
is just the best but I'll be better than
Bernie because I'm Native American like
she really has no reason why she'll be
better than Bernie so here's Elizabeth
Warren not really hitting Bernie so look
the way I see this is that Bernie is
winning right now because the Democratic
Party is a Progressive Party and
progressive ideas are popular ideas even
if there are a lot of people on this
stage who don't want to say so getting a
progressive agenda enacted is going to
be really hard and it's gonna take
someone who digs into the details to
make it happen okay so that that is you
know a really really failed attack by
Elizabeth one because it's not meant as
an attack
it was meant as more of an
to why I should be Bernie's
vice-president then there's people who
to judge and Buddha judges pitch is do
you really want Trump vs. Bernie now
honestly this is a fairly good pitch
right I mean the pitch is do you really
want this bleep show to go on all year
it's not a bad pitch the problem is that
nobody actually loves Peabody dredge all
that much other than journalists who are
college-educated white people living in
New York I mean other than that Buddha
judge has no base so here is here's
Buddha judge making his case against
Bernie and again it is not based on
principle it's based on like aren't
these old people annoying I'll tell you
what the Russians want they don't have a
political party they want chaos and
chaos is what is coming our way I mean
look if you think the last four years
has been chaotic divisive toxic
exhausting imagine spending the better
part of 2020 with Bernie Sanders versus
Donald Trump yeah that is a that is a
fairly good pitch the problem is that
Buddha judge isn't gonna prevent any of
that everybody knows it now the only
attack from the right on Bernie Sanders
came from Tom Styer and it felt
completely flat so steyr will get his
competitive in South Carolina but
nowhere else he says I don't like the
fact that Bernie's a commie and I don't
like it bothers me now normally this is
a good attack the problem is that again
the Democratic base is largely on board
with many of the things that Bernie said
because they grafted off of his off of
his plan thread his medicare-for-all
plan half the field grafted off of it
and now steyr is like yeah you know
maybe we shouldn't nominate a communist
it doesn't really go anywhere I don't
like his solutions I don't believe that
a government takeover of large parts of
the economy makes any sense for working
people or for families I think that what
we need to do is to present an
alternative that includes a vibrant
competitive private sector and that that
that of course is not gonna have any
real truck with a lot of Democrats and
Biden launched his own attack on Sanders
either so weak t-there's so et you have
a geriatric communist standing before
you who has endorsed every authoritarian
regime of the last half century and
who's been a useless human being for the
last six decades of his life and your
best attack is he didn't vote in favor
of the Brady Bill this is Joe Biden
trying to attack Sanders from the left
trying to say that Sanders hasn't
committed enough to progressivism good
luck with this attack you can't attack
Bernie Sanders from the left it's just
not possible here is Joe Biden trying it
though Bernie
voted five times against the Brady Bill
and wanted a waiting period of 12 hours
I'm not saying he's responsible for the
nine deaths but that man would not been
able to get that weapon with the waiting
period had been what I suggest until you
are cleared in addition to that being
progressive he thought Barack Obama he
wanted a primary he saying we should
primary Barack Obama
someone should and in fact the president
was weak and our administration was in
fact not up to it again in the attack on
on Bernie from the left on guns that's
not gonna have any any sort of play and
Bernie did respond by saying I got that
one wrong but I've had to do mine this
from the NRA of a since and I hope to
get enough okay that's actually not a
terrible answer hey finally
Bernie responds to all of us and he
responds and patented wild-eyed
communist fashion he basically says
everybody's attacking me up here tonight
because they know that I'm the
front-runner and I'm the front-runner
because I'm a communist Manchin I'm
hearing my name mentioned a little bit
tonight and maybe you know Pete mentions
what the American people want I'll tell
you people what the American people want
and Joe what the American people want
they don't want candidates to be running
to billionaires for huge amounts of
funding yeah and this again this stuff
has been playing I mean he's just keep
playing the hits I'll say this about
Bernie Bernie doesn't have a lot new to
say but do plays the hits I mean if you
go to Doobie Brothers concert you want
to hear listen to the music and if you
go to a Bernie Sanders debate you want
to hear billionaires and so that was
that meanwhile Biden did in fact
basically say he has to win South
Carolina this was maybe the only big
news of the debate Biden basically said
I will win South Carolina he didn't
pledge you get out if he doesn't but
realistically speaking if he doesn't win
South Carolina he's toast
here is Biden admitting as much if you
do not win South Carolina you said that
South Carolina will determine the
outcome of this presidential race if you
don't win South Carolina will you
continue iring win South Carolina okay
so that is his pledge that is his pledge
now will it happen maybe and if he does
then it makes the race a lot more
interesting for sure but if Bernie gets
more delegates than Biden he's gonna end
up with the nomination and meanwhile
that was like the first 10 minutes of
debate all of us then everybody just
decides you know what how about
I want to have his bag on Bloomberg what
happened seriously like everyone
particularly Elizabeth Warren who is
just openly campaigning like she's in
the middle of the debate she walked over
to Bernie's podium and and slipped him a
resume for VP I mean like she she
slipped him a binder full of women like
Mitt Romney like she wanted it's so
obvious
she's so obvious and so transparent and
so terrible Elizabeth Warren and so
about ten minutes into the bait she
swivels and she just starts clocking
Bloomberg again like clocking the
horse and in blazing Saddles cuz
Bloomberg ain't the front-runner
Bloomberg is fading in the polls
Bloomberg is not making a difference in
this race so Elizabeth Warren to prove
her bona fide ease right she's out there
like Luca Brasi trying to prove her
trying to prove her fealty to the dawn
and so here is here is Elizabeth Warren
going after Michael Bloomberg and
suggesting that he's discriminatory
against women this time by telling a lie
again she's told this story before this
story where she was supposedly
discriminated against on the basis of
her pregnancy documentary evidence shows
that this is highly unlikely that she
was actually offered to retain her
teaching position unanimously in the
school district in which she talks about
how she was discriminated against as a
woman she was falsified nearly every
aspect of her own personal background
but she uses that to hit Michael
Bloomberg because she is woman hear her
complain the principal wished me luck
and gave my job to someone else
pregnancy discrimination you bet but I
was 21 years old I didn't have a union
to protect me and I didn't have any
federal law on my side so I packed up my
stuff and I went home at least I didn't
have a boss who said to me kill it
the way that I Mayor Bloomberg never
have said to one of Pokemon pregnant
employees okay I mean that that is just
her showing off to Bernie Sanders at
this point by the way that's an
allegation it's never been proved in
court that he said kill it if he did
obviously it's a super evil thing to say
I am amused to watch Democrats suddenly
realized that telling people to get
abortions is a bad idea and I was under
the impression that they're very much in
favor of women need to be empowered by
having abortions so apparently it only
bad when Bloomberg says it but if they
make that their entire national platform
then apparently it's not it's not a bad
thing anymore
and she continued along this line I mean
the whole really for a solid half-hour
it was just Warren bagging on Bloomberg
to prove that she was loyal to Bernie
Sanders she continued to
these lines Norah O'Donnell asked
Bloomberg about jokes about women and
how is it that we go through an entire
debate were Bernie Sanders at the
front-runner and he's never asked about
the fact that he literally held in the
1970s that women who don't have orgasms
get cancer
okay I'm not kidding about that that is
a thing and that Bernie Sanders wrote
back in the 1970s in fact he's on tape
talking about in the 1970s and 80s that
women who were sexually repressed were
more likely to get cancer how does he
not get asked about that but Bloomberg
gets asked about everything the answer
is because nobody's willing to ask
Sanders a tough question
here's Norah O'Donnell asking Bloomberg
a question and then Warren jumping in
with both feet to try and destroy
Bloomberg to prove that she is is loyal
to Bernie did these women take your
jokes wrong or were you wrong to make
the jokes probably wrong to make the
jokes I don't remember what they were so
I assume i if it bothered them I was
wrong and I apologize I'm sorry for that
and it just just and then she says you
didn't do what I asked why is it up to
Bloomberg to do what she asks since when
is a who made Elizabeth Warren Queen but
of course this is the I'm a woman on
this stage and I'm going to hold
Bloomberg to account really what it's
about again he's taking down Bloomberg
at Sanders his behest when you spend all
your time attacking the guy who is
running like third in the national
polling then you that sort of betrays
what exactly you are doing Elizabeth
Warren okay meanwhile senator Sanders
has no answers to anything so Norah
O'Donnell asked Sanders about the cost
of his agenda and Sanders has literally
no answer to this and no one seems to
care senator Sanders our cost of your
agenda yesterday you released
information about how you will pay for
your major proposals but not all of your
details are clear you proposed more than
50 trillion dollars in new spending
you've said Medicare for all will 30
trillion dollars but you can only
explain how you'll pay for just about
half of that can you do the math for the
rest of us how many hours do you have
- I mean a that it's such a terrible
answer how many if it takes you that
long to answer how you're gonna pay for
all of this stuff that means you don't
have an answer because he doesn't have
an answer P Buddha judge again I think
that Buddha judges the best debater on
the stage I think he's the most talented
politician on the stage just in pure raw
terms ok Buddha judge was the only
person willing to call out Sanders on
this stuff and and he does but the
problem is that the moderators won't let
Buddha judge get an award in edgewise
this is one of the big stories of the
night is the CBS moderators were just
awful last night and no point did they
step in and act like adults instead they
just let everybody squabble it sounded
like my kids in the back of the car when
they can't decide which Star Wars movie
to watch here's a here's P Buddha judge
going after Sanders but not being able
to get a word in edgewise talking about
maths and it doesn't take two hours
let's talk about Matt Matt let's talk
about that map I think we should talk
about Matt Matt what is it why hey and
it continued like this I mean this is
one of the themes of the night is that
ever is that they weren't able to
control it enough that anybody could get
a solid shot in at Sanders right Buddha
judge tries it again like one second
later and again he is not allowed to
finish this point if you want to keep
the house in democratic hands you might
want to check with the people who
actually turn the house blue forty
Democrats who are not running on your
platform they are running away from your
platform as fast as they possibly can
that of course is exactly true but
doesn't matter because doesn't matter
okay then there was Joe Biden so Joe
Biden he's the front-runner to South
Carolina I mean less we forget he
actually is the polling frontrunner in
South Carolina he was a longtime
front-runner in this race so Biden's
only thing that he did last night who's
basically irrelevant last night he only
did one thing and that was he just kept
saying that he wanted to talk last night
his pitch was I'm here and I'm alive and
everybody was like okay Joe sure sure so
what he was really going for was not in
1980 Ronald Reagan was on the ropes
against George HW Bush in in some of the
early primaries there was a very famous
New Hampshire debate at which at which
Ronald Reagan had paid
or part of the debate because all the
campaign's paid for part of the debate
and when the moderator tried to shut up
Reagan and Reagan had this very famous
moment it was it was considered one of
the turning points of the campaign or
suddenly he got mad or something he
didn't look old anymore he got mad and
he said I paid for this microphone mr.
green who was actually mr. Brean was the
name of the guy but here is that moment
from Ronald Reagan this is clear I'm
playing this cuz this is clearly what
Biden was trying to channel last night
here's Ronald Reagan circa 1980 the song
man please turns to writers my
is this mr. green you turn out like me
okay so is that moment for Reagan that
really turned things around watch Biden
try to channel Reagan right here versus
Tom Styer and he kept going back to the
well on this is clip 14 out of time you
spoke over time and I'm gonna talk
here's the deal and then the crowd
cheers a little bit here's the he spoke
over time and I'm gonna talk crowd
Cheers and then the best part of this
was he's like here's the deal here's the
deal and at the end of the clip has
nothing to say he literally has nothing
to say so he's like I'm gonna talk I
paid for this microphone and and then
you just sort of shuffles off distance
that was considered a fairly good move
for for Joe Biden but whatever whatever
the fact is that that Biden himself did
not have a wonderful night he didn't
have a particularly great night last
night he did show that he was a little
bit lively there's the possibility that
he does well in South Carolina I don't
think that it's well enough to stop
Bernie Sanders his rise but you know
that that was his big moment his big
moment was I'm alive right he did it
again by the way clip 20 you'll see Joe
Biden do the exact same thing you just
cut once he got a cheer he just kept
going back to the well like a bad
comedian telling the same joke over and
over we've got to deal with Institute at
Grayson vice president mr. president I
note how you cut me off all the time but
I'm not going to be quiet anymore
okay I'm not gonna be quiet Ament he did
this I think four times last night this
is this I'm gonna I'm gonna talk and
you're not gonna stop me from talking
and stop talking no one's trying to stop
you from talking Joe you just have not
had anything to say for like a year and
a half so that would be your big problem
okay we're getting more of the
democratic debate plus the media
reaction to the democratic debate we'll
get to all of that momentarily first The
Daily wires on Mount Walsh has a new
book out it's called Church of cowards a
wake-up call to complacent Christians
Christians and other countries are still
being martyred for their faith but how
many American Christians are willing to
lay down their smartphones let alone
their lives for the faith
well Walsh breaks down the problems
found in modern American Christianity go
pick up a copy of Matt's new book at
Amazon or Barnes & Noble today I've read
it it really is a good read whether you
are Christian or whether you are not
also if you have jumped on the daily
water party bus a readers pass it's a
great way to dip your toe into the
community if you're obsessed with new
a reader's pass will enable you to read
our articles ad-free including my op-eds
which are exclusive for daily wire
members only you also get access to our
mobile apps read our stories and receive
push notifications for breaking news and
special content which is perfect for
when you want to stay up to date on the
go this membership tier is already a
bargain at 3 bucks a month if you are
still hesitant check out our special
magical offer right now we are offering
1 month and 99 cents that is mobile ad
free access to all of daily Wired news
exclusive op-eds from yours truly
breaking news and updates on our mobile
app all for the low price of one dollar
give it a shot I think you will be
hooked by the way next Tuesday March 3rd
join me god-king Jeremy boring Andrew
Clavin and Michael mole Sante Lee Weyer
backstage while we watched the results
from Super Tuesday roll in and roll in
and roll in it will be interminable it
will be long I will suffer through it
all for you go check out daily wire.com
right now make the magic happen for
yourself become a member you are
listening to the largest fastest scoring
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
so as I say Joe Biden didn't have a
great night last night his big his big
move last night was to show that he was
alive he didn't stop gaffing a clip 16
Biden basically says that that half of
Americans have been killed by gun
violence which is which is news to half
of Americans who are sitting there alive
I'm like maybe Joe Biden here is Joe
Biden completely botching statistics on
guns but my friend am i right and others
have in fact also given to the gun
manufacturers absolute immunity imagine
if I stood here and said we give
immunity to drug companies we give
immunity tobacco companies that is
caused carnage on our streets a hundred
and fifty million people have been
killed since 2007 when Bernie voted to
exempt the gun manufacturers from
liability more than all the wars
including Vietnam from that point on 150
million Americans dead from gun violence
I probably I figure I would have heard
something about that my god and things
were getting bad okay so so here's what
you have you have the geriatric
communist and we'll get to the only
attack on him
that really made a difference last night
at all was the attack that he is Pro
authoritarianism it's were able to
actually land this blow which is
unbelievable it's unbelievable then you
had Mayor Bloomberg who basically was
just standing up there taken the brunt
of the attacks I mean just taken the
hits and also demonstrating that he is
the worst in clip 22 Bloomberg basically
says that he would like to nationally
ban trans fats and sugary drinks and all
sorts of good things that people like
here's here's nanny-state Bloomberg
explaining that he'd like to make it the
nanny federal state Mayor Bloomberg as
mayor of New York you declared war on
obesity you ban trans fats from
restaurants and you tried to do the same
with large sugary drinks so if you
become president will you push those
policies on the national level as well
well I think what's right for New York
City isn't necessarily right but all the
other cities otherwise you'd have a
naked cowboy in every city so let's get
serious here but I do think it's the
government's job to have good science
and to explain to people what science
says how to take care of themselves and
extend their lives
well what at what ass wait well well
done everybody what a slate you've come
up with a dead person a nanny stator and
a geriatric communist well really well
done okay so finally ninety minutes into
the debate ninety minutes into the
debate the controversy of the day which
should have been minute one of this
debate comes up right and that is Bernie
Sanders praising Cuba because he's
praised Cuba he's president Kuran why
he's praised Venezuela he is praised the
Soviet Union the man has never met a
communist regime for which he does not
have warm words okay this is what he
does so clip 26 is the one we're looking
for
so bernie is asked again about Cuba and
he says sure it's a dictatorship but I
just love Barack Obama said I mean it's
it's a dictatorship but they have great
literacy I mean sure they've greatly you
should notice the country there is
there's a very interesting contrast
between how Bernie Sanders talks about
the United States and how he talks about
authoritarianism so most of us in the
United States if you ask us you know
what about the problems in the United
States well say yes absolutely there are
problems in the United States but it is
the freest best most moral system ever
created right that America has had its
problems continues to have its problems
but what justifies the system is the
fact that the system itself is good and
self-correcting and has the capacity for
self correction sure there's income
inequality but we are also the most
prosperous country in world history sure
we've had serious horrible historic
problems with discrimination in this
country but we have worked to fix them
we have worked toward a more perfect
union because that's our system of
government it's the system of government
that has found self-justifying Bernie
Sanders however we'll talk about sure
America is I mean we say we have a
democracy but we don't really have a
democracy if it really a democracy with
income inequality the way that it is and
then you will talk about authoritarian
States and he will say well should this
authoritarianism but the literacy there
is really great so in other words Bernie
defends authoritarian States the way
most Americans defend America and he
rips into America the waste most
Americans rip into authoritarian States
or if you're an American and somebody
says to you Cuba has great literacy
rates you're like right and also the
imprisoned dissidents and kill people
they don't like and people live in
poverty because their system is garbage
so if somebody were to say to you a good
thing about like what's happening in
Cuba the normal human reaction is right
but that's so overwhelmed by the bad
that that doesn't even that doesn't even
chart and if somebody were to say to you
here's a bad thing that's happening in
America I'd say right
that's bad but the American system is so
overwhelmed with good that as on a
contrasting basis that is not really a
close call
Bernie reverses the polarity right in
America all the good is outweighed by
the bad and in evil authoritarian
countries kind of shuffle off they'll
pay the lip service - I don't like what
toward tourism but you got to admit
everybody couldn't read and that's how
Bernie talks about authoritarian so last
night he's asked about Cuba and he
dumped it he triples down on the defense
of Cuba's literacy programs which is
just an amazing move for a guy who
supposedly wants to win Florida here is
there's Bernie you got a real
dictatorship there of course you have a
dictatorship in Cuba what I said is what
Barack Obama said in terms of Cuba that
Cuba made progress on education yes I
think really really occasionally it
might be good idea to be honest about
American foreign policy and that
includes the fact that America has
overthrown governments all over the
world in Chile in Guatemala in Iran and
when dictatorships whether it is the
Chinese or the Cubans do something good
you acknowledge that okay that's bad
bleep lunacy so that every element of
that is crazy so when he says that
America has overthrown regimes in
Guatemala in Chile in Iran first of all
he's getting the facts wrong in some of
these cases particularly in Iran he's
getting the facts wrong but when he says
that we have to acknowledge that America
is bad in the world and we have to
acknowledge when dictatorships like the
Chinese or the Cubans that do something
good and then when he says you don't
have to trade love-letters with them he
literally traded love letters with
Daniel Ortega and Nicaragua I mean he
literally went down to Nicaragua and
then traded and then swapped spit with
Daniel Ortega the man went to Cuba he
came back and he talked about how the
Cuban people worshipped Castro now it
was really funny because some of the
other Democrats were like yeah you're
easy on authoritarian says no I've
always condemned authoritarianism this
is where being a Democrat you know you
guys might want to do your research
because wouldn't it have be moved you to
say well Bernie actually we haven't
condemned authoritarianism everywhere in
fact you've supported authoritarians all
over the globe and then quoted chap
in verse four all the things that I've
cited before how he's talked about how
the Soviet Union bread lines are good
how they have wonderful bussing programs
how they are moving toward the vision of
1917 Cuba how all the people worship
Castro Nicaragua house Daniel Ortega is
like Abraham Lincoln with hit with
habeas corpus now in Venezuela last year
last year you refused to declare Nicolas
Maduro a dictator how does nobody say
that on the stage how how is that even
humanly possible bernie is a Howard Zinn
know'm Chomsky leftist that is where he
is he believes that America is a
nefarious force in the world he is more
concerned with all of these supposed
evils of American foreign policy than he
is with actual dictatorships that keep
millions of people in near slavery
conditions and he has not been hit on
that it's really incredible and if you
think the Trump won't come after him he
will come after him and he will come
after him hard
that wasn't the extent of Bernie Sanders
radicalism last night naturally he saved
his harshest words right he was fine
with Cuba and China and all the rest of
us he saved his harshest words for
Israel because it's a proud Jew who
campaigns with open anti-semites who
want to destroy the State of Israel and
push the Jews into the sea that guys
have proud proud you major Garrett asked
him about this last night and apparently
the only regime on earth that is racist
is the is the Netanyahu administration
in Israel despite the fact that Israel
happens to be the only state in the
Middle East that actually has a minority
setting its parliament right it's the
only state in the Middle East where
there is a Arab party the joint list
that has 1314 seats in parliament where
where Arabs have full civil rights
here's Bernie Sanders basically calling
Israel racist because Bernie Sanders is
a retro gate he's a retro game communist
right I mean this is what he's following
the Stalinist line from the 1960s or the
Khrushchev line from the 1960s about
where exactly Israel is on the world
stage
I'd say here's Bernie Sanders completely
completely just watching this situation
worldwide he always has harsh words for
Israel than he does for any actual
dictatorship on planet earth because he
likes the commies he just doesn't like
the Jews very much what would you say to
American Jews who might be concerned
you're not from their perspective
supportive enough of Israel specifically
sir would you move the US Embassy back
to Tel Aviv let me just
the answer is it's something that we
would take into consideration but here
is the point I am very proud of being
Jewish I actually lived in Israel for
some months but when I happen to believe
is that right now sadly tragically in
Israel through Bibi Netanyahu you have a
reactionary racist who is now running
that country and I happen to believe I
happen to believe that what our foreign
policy in the Mideast should be about is
absolutely protecting the independence
and security of Israel but you cannot
ignore the suffering of the Palestinian
people he has never once never once
taken a position in favor in terms of
his public policy of the independence
and security of the State of Israel and
he campaigns with people who openly call
for its destruction and then he says I'm
a Jew and I spent time on a kibbutz
congratulations dude I mean seriously
like back in 1968 you spent like six
months on a kibbutz last time I checked
it's 2020 right and last time I checked
you're out there campaigning with Linda
Sarsour
you're out there campaign with ohon omar
and rashida to lead so spare me the
hysterics about how your pro-israel i
mean it's obviously a joke by the way
one of the great wise that was told up
on the stage last night is that first of
all the israel palestine issue is
central to Middle East it is not second
why is when he suggests that Bibi
Netanyahu is sort of the be-all end-all
in Israel okay first of all Bennigan's
who is B B's Prime Opposition in Israel
has exactly the same foreign policy
position is Bibi with regard to the
Palestinians he embraced Trump's peace
plan which is worth noting okay so in
the aftermath of all of this what
happens the answer is not much of
anything Biden has probably a slight
increase in sort of public perception I
don't think Bernie had a good night by
any stretch of the imagination but it
doesn't damage him enough to stop him
from getting the nomination South
Carolina Biden's gonna need to win big
in order for things to to really change
for him on the national level Bloomberg
has basically been exposed as a
nonentity and then after the debate by
the way Bernie just he kept doubling
down tripling down quadrupling now again
he praised Cuba after the debate again I
mean just can't let go praising the
authoritarian sits unbelievable if
somebody in Saudi Arabia or any country
in the world teaches illiterate
people to read they get something that's
a bad thing it is not Barack Obama made
the point that Cuba had made good
progress and health care and education
Cuba is a dictatorship I've said that 8
million times but that does not mean to
say as Obama pointed out that even under
a dictatorship you could teach people to
read and to write video it's really
willing to die on this hill he's really
willing to die on this hill of communist
regimes do the things it's pretty
incredible now how do I think things are
gonna end up again I think Bernie
remains the national frontrunner I think
he has a lot of momentum in states like
California I think he's racked up a
delegate lead in some of these other
places in again the moderates are
hurting each other Bloomberg is actually
gonna hurt Biden if I had to put money
on South Carolina I do think Biden pulls
out South Carolina so I wouldn't said
that a week ago I think that Bernie's
been a little bit dinged up i think that
james Clyburn coming out in favor of Joe
Biden's the congressman from South
Carolina coming out in favor of Joe
Biden is a is a big move I think that
Biden is likely to win South Carolina
and I think it's gonna be a little
broader than I would have thought even a
week ago I don't think he's gonna win
narrow so it could make the race kind of
interesting I mean that would definitely
live in things up again because Bernie
seems to have had this sort of
unstoppable momentum it would be the
first time in recent memory that a
firewall has actually worked
James Carville pointed out last night
that the Bernie did get roughed up a
little bit Barney Sanders is it the
first time he's really gotten roughed up
a little bit and he didn't like it
I think this old admitted he looked like
he had a cold was just something he
wasn't terrible don't get me wrong I'm
not calm down Bernie rose but he was not
he was just he was just a little off he
just wasn't quite himself and then Jones
came out he said he can't believes that
Sanders didn't walk back all the cuba's
stuff like this is not this is not
alleviating people's concerns about his
electability I was disappointed with
birdies answer on the socialism question
he had to know that was coming
there's no reason to do a big
retrospective nostalgia scream fest
about
authoritarian regimes from the 70s
there's a opportunity for Bernie to
clarify the American people then when he
says democratic socialism that's the
point it's not that stuff in Cuba it's
not that stuff in Soviet Union it's the
stuff that you see in northern Europe is
working well for normal people and they
vote all the time
he failed to do that it's unbelievable
he failed to do it it's what a big chunk
of our party needs to hear from him and
he did not do it tonight okay what
you're starting to see from the
Democrats is they're now in sort of the
final stages of grief right they they've
done the denial stage where it can't be
Bernie it definitely can't be Bernie it
won't be Bernie and now they're getting
toward acceptance which is okay well I
guess maybe it'll be Bernie David
Axelrod doing that routine so Axelrod is
smart enough to recognize that Bernie is
a dangerous candidate for his party but
Axelrod last night was saying don't
worry Bernie's not a socialist it
doesn't matter that he spends his entire
life being a communist fellow-traveller
don't worry Bernie's not a real social
she's just like a normal Democrat the
Republicans and Donald Trump we're gonna
make this same case against any
Democratic candidate but it's easier to
make when that Democratic candidate
embraces the title of socialist and
doesn't refute it and the truth of the
matter is Bernie Sanders is not a
socialist I mean if you look it up in
the dictionary he's not calling for you
know this oh this is society own the
means of production and all of that
stuff and why he is so reluctant to make
that point and why is why he is like a
fortress Andrew but not on that question
tonight by the way the backstop for
Democrats is going to be eventually and
they're getting there very quickly that
yes okay fine
Bernie might be economy my okay yeah
we'll say maybe the Communists all right
but you know he's not gonna win the
Senate so he's not gonna be able to
effectuate any of this stuff anyway that
is not a strong pitch that is really
really not a strong pitch so that is
where things stand going into South
Carolina that was the last major debate
before all of this happens then the next
the next election is happening on
February 29th is happening in South
Carolina and we will find out very
quickly whether Biden is still a viable
candidate at this point Biden is the
only viable candidate who has the
possibility of stopping Sanders from
taking the nomination so I guess that
debate did a little bit of damage to
Bernie but not enough to I think blunt
the the reality which is that he is the
front-runner okay time for a quick thing
that I like and then a quick thing that
I hate in fact you know what we're gonna
skip the things that I like we're gonna
go directly to the things that I hate so
things that I hate today so president
Trump is scheduled to give a little bit
later today a press conference on
coronavirus as I have said before I do
not think that this is the smartest move
I think the President of the United
States should be telling Alex azar his
health and human secretary is
the Human Services Secretary to give the
press conference why well because
President Trump doesn't know anything
about the science because he doesn't
pretend to know anything about the
science and because he is too busy
tweeting out dumb crap about coronavirus
so for example the president just this
morning tweeted out a tweet it tweeted
this out low ratings fake news MS DNC
Comcast and CNN are doing everything
possible to make the coronavirus spelled
ciear oh and avi our US current
coronavirus look as bad as possible
including panicking markets if possible
likewise they're incompetent do-nothing
Democrats are all talk no action USA in
great shape CDC will be having a news
conference at the White House on this
subject today at 6 p.m.
CDC representatives and others will be
there thank you okay okay attacking the
media for the coverage of coronavirus is
not gonna make anybody feel any better
okay well you actually need to do is
spell out your plans for all of this
apparently that's going to happen a
little bit later today he's lashing out
at the media in all of this but I gotta
be honest with you like I have young
kids I am an American who worries about
pandemics I think most Americans at this
point are worried about pandemics the
stock market has been off dramatically
over the last couple of days it is back
up somewhat today a little bit of a
balance today but it is not quieting
when the president of the United States
is out there just sort of spouting about
coronavirus like this is the time when
an actual message discipline should
kicking this is the time when the
administration says today here are the
steps that we are taking in order to
prevent the spread of coronavirus this
is not the time to be going on Twitter
and sounding off about coronavirus and
misspelling coronavirus or suggesting
that a vaccine is being developed for
coronavirus well you really mean with
Ebola it's just not the time for any of
this it's not that's not like this is
the time when Trump needs to sit down
and let his people do their jobs and
please for the love of Pete stop
tweeting okay another thing that I hate
today now if you want to rip on the
media there's plenty of good reason
strip on the media here's a great reason
to rip on the media so James O'Keefe
over at Project Veritas has once again
uncovered people in the media making
asses of themselves so David Wright is
an ABC News correspondent and as we've
been saying for a very long time news
correspondents have perspectives right
Jim Acosta has
perspective his perspective is that that
dude love's Jim Acosta but some people
have actual political perspectives and
David Wright who's a correspondent for
ABC News he has one of those
perspectives so Project Veritas caught
him on camera talking about how he is a
socialist and how he buries particular
stories in order to achieve particular
purposes basically admitting the truth
about how the media business works
okay so he openly admits that the media
will not give Trump credit for the
things that he does do and they will
bury stories it'll bury stories yeah
that is an amazing thing now it's not
amazing because we didn't know what of
course we did know it but it's amazing
because they admit it and they all know
it right I mean that this is the the
question about many members of the media
was originally whether the members of
the media knew what they're doing or
whether this is all just sort of an echo
chamber and they don't even think about
it
whether they're so ensconced in the
cycle chamber of people who agree with
them that it never even occurs to them
that what they are doing is bad and
wrong and vicious but David right
basically blows the lid off that he's
like yeah sure I'm a socialist and we
bury stories that's it he says oh yeah I
consider myself a socialist not just a
democratic socialist like a full-on
socialist incredible he says it's so ABC
News suspended David right yesterday the
network disciplined him he reports for
World News Tonight Good Morning America
and Nightline he says I don't think
we're terribly interested in voters he
says commercial imperative is
incompatible with news and he says we
don't hold him to account we also don't
give him credit for the things that he
does do the him would be President Trump
and then he refers to Trump at another
point as the effing president ABC
according to the Washington Post was
also alarmed that Wright's criticism of
ABC News which is owned by Disney
Corporation at another point he raises
another long-standing critique of ABC
News that it blends news with promotion
of Disney on movies and TV programs he
says you can't watch Good Morning
America without there being a Disney
Princess or a marvel of engineering it's
all self promotional well that's true
but if you're talking
about media bias in favor of things like
Marvel Avengers seem to be the least of
the problems ABC News said in a
statement any action that damages our
reputation for fairness or impartiality
or gives the appearance of compromising
it harms ABC News and the individuals
involved David Wright has been suspended
and to avoid any possible appearance of
bias he will be reassigned away from
political coverage when he returns
okay well wouldn't it behoove you to
just simply admit who you are this is
one of my big Bugaboos about the media
I've said this about John lemon on
Anderson Cooper on CNN like we all know
where you are politically this nonsense
where you pretend to be objective or
even straining for objectivity in any
way is ridiculous and we all know that
it's ridiculous I've told this story
before but I remember Sam Donaldson who
recently came out endorse Michael
Bloomberg correspondent for ABC News for
a very very long time Sam Donald Thomas
at the 2012 RNC and I was there as well
in beautiful Tampa and I was walking the
floor and I come across Sam Donaldson
and his eyebrows and I walk up to him
and he's doing like these little radio
hits for ABC News at the time and their
perspective pieces right perspective
pieces on why the left is right and why
the right is wrong in all of this and I
go up to him and I say so Sam did you
hold these views back when you were
journalists and he says of course I did
and I said well isn't it dishonest for
you to have held those views and clearly
known how you felt about these things
and then cover the news in a non
objective way and got very upset with me
very upset those eyebrows came at me
from the dark and he said and in Tim
Donaldson said do you think you're
better than me you think you're better
you saying you're better than me and I
said well I mean kind of like yeah cuz
um I say Who I am right now I'm a
conservative I'm covering news from a
conservative perspective I'm not lying
about any of this stuff and Sam
Donaldson was very frustrated by this
but this is the great lie that the media
have been telling themselves for years
is that one they are objective two that
they are capable of objectivity
despite their deeply held political
beliefs honestly if they would just say
upfront yeah I'm a Democrat and then
cover the news they'd be so much better
off there's a reason that I don't bother
to critique how MSNBC covers the news
they're all Democrats we all know
they're Democrats so pointing out their
bias is manifestly stupid doing the same
about ABC News or CNN however is a very
different thing all they're doing is
handing Trump a club with which to beat
them obviously also worth pointing out
good on James O'Keefe right O'Keefe
continues to have a string of successes
in exposing members of the media it
turns out all you have to
put a camera and somebody's face in the
media and they're willing to tell you
about their own biases O'Keefe is doing
more honest reporting than many members
of the mainstream media I mean at least
O'Keefe will ask the reporters questions
the reporters won't even ask Bernie
Sanders questions Wright has been at ABC
for 20 years he has covered the White
House and was Nightline's lead political
reporter during the 2016 presidential
campaign their lead
political reporter acknowledging that
stories were buried to damage president
Trump he shared a 2004 Emmy Award for
his reporting from Iraq shared a Peabody
Award for reporting in Afghanistan after
September 11th so again well done on
Project Veritas and it is hysterically
funny that ABC thinks that by suspending
him they're going to quiet all the
questions because clearly they are not
already we'll be back here later to do
two additional hours quick note by the
way next Tuesday March 3rd again join me
Jeremy boring and reclaim in Michael
Mills on Daily wire backstage we will
watch the results from two Super Tuesday
roll in we'll find out whether that
Bernie Red juggernaut is able to run
through Super Tuesday and take the
nomination after Super Tuesday that's
things basically over so we'll have
results for you live on Super Tuesday
we'll be here basically all day long all
day long with a wide variety of coterie
of magical guests a cavalcade of stars
so come check us out over at Daly where
to comment subscribe get all the great
behind-the-scenes material of so much
good stuff coming for you you won't even
believe it otherwise show up here later
today for two additional hours or
tomorrow when we recap everything
happening in the news I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas
directed by Mike joiner executive
producer Jeremy boring supervising
producer Mathis clever and Robert
Stirling assistant director Pavel why
douse key technical producer austin
stevens playback and media operated by
Nick Sheehan associate producer Katie
Swinton edited by Adam SIA vets
audio is mixed by micro Romina hair and
makeup is by Nika Geneva the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 25 on the Matt
Walsh oh we're not just discussing
politics we're talking culture faith
family all of the things that are really
important to you so come join the
conversation
[Music]